five years ago I spent $5,000 on a
trashcan MacPro it was expensive but it
was the right move for me at the time
fast forward to today when Apple just
announced the next Mac Pro a machine
that so many Mac fans have been waiting
for and the overall consensus is that
they missed the mark since the release
of the trashcan Mac Pro my video
business has grown by at least four
times so I definitely could afford a new
Mac Pro but there's no way that I'm
gonna buy one and I'll explain exactly
why before you dislike this video and
leave a nasty comment hear me out until
the end and I think you'll end up
agreeing with me and if you don't go
ahead and comment all you want I think
Apple made a big mistake with the new
Mac Pro and like many people who are
flooding to the comments sections of
YouTube videos and Mac web sites now the
apples carts have been revealed I've
decided that I'm not gonna buy the
stainless steel and aluminum beauty
what is it professional anyways well the
definition comes up as a person engaged
in a specific activity as once made paid
occupation rather than a pastime as many
Apple apologists are pointing out that's
who Apple is targeting with the Mac Pro
not prosumers hobbyists or people just
want to Mac Pro for the cool factor real
working pros and the real working Pro
market those who are engaged in the
specific activity as a main paid
occupation has been absolutely exploding
ever since the original Mac Pro was
released from about seven million 2006
to an expected 42 million by next year
and a huge number of these working pros
are creatives like web developers
photographers videographers graphics
artists animators and yes full-time
youtubers so what does that while doing
to capture this new market that's in its
prime time to invest in a solid computer
that can be expanded long term while
charging six thousand dollars for a week
based configuration that will likely
need to be SPECT up closer than eight
thousand or maybe ten thousand dollars
to offer decent performance for the
money please don't get me wrong I am NOT
an Apple hater far from it actually my
family practically lives on expensive
Apple devices and a lot of these are
excellent and worth of money but with
the new Mac Pro Apple is still out of
touch in the past it was with their slow
upgrade cycles and trying to make
everything seal their proprietary we're
just trying to be too courageous or
innovative can't innovate anymore my ass
sure there are still pros that will end
up using these most of which are
employees for corporations or large
production houses that have huge profits
and need the ride offs but from what
I've seen working in the video industry
these positions are slowly starting to
shrink up as many go up to pursue a
creative profession themselves the Mac
Pro used to be great for this market
which is now roughly three to four times
larger than before every previous Mac
Pro started at around $3,000 when
adjusted for inflation which is a good
entry-level price point for a base level
pro computer that could be upgraded when
needed and when the budget allows I
think everybody would agree that Apple
made the right choice going back to a
modular Mac Pro but what's the point if
the base system is out of reach for most
of the working pros and even then the
specs are weak I don't mind it starting
with a a core CPU which is no longer a
hike or count or impressive in terms of
performance or a three year old graphics
card that launched at $230 or a measly
256 gigabytes of SSD that's slower than
a MacBook Pros is the base same config
that was offered six years ago and is
actually four times smaller than iMac
pros and I even don't mind 32 gigabytes
of RAM which is not bad in and of itself
until you realize that those eons are
designed to be used with six channeled
memory and Apple is shipping it with
four I completely understand the need to
offer a $40,000 computer for large
corporations but why not also give lower
budget working pros the chance to get in
the door like they used to with every
pass Mac Pro well for a few reasons
first off they're going back to a
modular system which means they have
less control on how much money they can
make from you since you can upgrade the
parts to yourself so the need to have a
good profit from the very beginning
second is the iMac Pro when Apple
admitted that the trashcan was a failure
in 2017 they promised a modular Mac in a
few years but announced I Mac Pro at the
time being which made it seem almost
like a stopgap since Apple price the Mac
Pro as $6,000 it definitely seems like
the Mac Pro is here to stay long term
and the only way to guarantee not
cannibalizing this high-end all-in-one
is by pricing the Mac Pro higher and
with lower specs you also have to keep
in mind that Apple's profits have been
going down recently and to combat it
they're trying to compensate
by raising the average sales price of
their products if Apple could raise the
base price they will like the new Mac
minis MacBook Airs
and even iPhones for products that need
to stay at an entry-level price they
keep outdated like the base 13-inch
MacBook Pro which still ships with
faulty second-generation butterfly keys
instead of being updated to the 4:3
vision and dual-core processors where
the whole industry has moved over to
quad-core Apple has been saying that the
BC market is shrinking and the trashcan
Mac Pro sales were single digits of
their overall sales
maybe that's because the trashcan
couldn't be upgraded which forced people
to look elsewhere and many of those that
stuck around waiting are now out priced
from the new Mac Pro with this price
point Apple is clearly targeting
corporations and high profit studios but
that market is much smaller than the
millions of pros and also the Mac fans
that have site hustles or just those
that love it can afford a $3,000 desktop
Mac no the Mac Pro is no longer for them
only for the elites some will their luck
Tinley end up with sealed IMAX's they've
been trying to avoid but judging by the
comments on Apple centric websites and
YouTube channels for many this will be
the final straw that will force them
away from Apple thank you for watching
this video if you agree please give it a
thumbs up and leave a nice comment below
to offset all of the negative ones if
you want to see more videos like this
one click that little circle above to
subscribe and go ahead and check out our
video on iPad OS which is actually an
awesome move from Apple this has been
max and I'll see you in the next one and
the pro stand $9.99 and like the mac pro
they'll all be available in this in the
fall